the trump supporters are crying
foul as the president's lead in georgia
has slowly narrowed
and tensions arising with it
it's still too close to call but the
trump loyalists are smelling a loss
now they're cheating they're making
ballots it's a fraud
they're clearly cheating the democrats
have dead people voting for him
they do this every single time this time
we're not putting up with it
if you know something is wrong stand up
if you feel like it's gonna hit the fan
join your local militia
they're still counting inside the state
farm arena in atlanta
and no one's taking bets right now on
who will be the presidential winner
thousands of votes are still to be
tallied but they are male
in ballots which tend to favor joe biden
and from counties that tend to vote blue
so a state which hasn't been democratic
since the 90s
is on the cusp of causing a massive and
critical upset
and this is one of the reasons why the
focus on the black vote
one of the campaigners was taking some
heat from the trump loyalists as she
passed by
people work really really hard to keep
us from voting and we keep showing up
so we are here to to demand that that
narrative is changed
we saw long lines of voters in the weeks
before
election day some waited 11 hours in
georgia
but they still broke the voting records
for turnout
the black voters mata campaign group has
been focusing hard on getting the vote
out
after lingering claims they've been
cheated out of victories in the past
most notably the state governors race
two years ago now they feel vindicated
despite the history of slavery despite
the fight for civil rights
despite reaganomics despite trickle-down
economics
despite all of the things that our
communities have faced
we still show up we're still committed
to the process
and we are still the ones who are
preserving democracy in this country
they're still working though to get the
vote out for probable runoffs for the
senate in january
democratic influence there could be
decided in georgia
this is likely to go down as a political
revolution in terms of just how many
votes they've managed to switch to the
democratic party
but it also shows just how divided the
people of georgia are
and maybe how representative they are of
the whole of america
alex crawford sky news atlanta